what is going on there reject nation we
are back at it again today to talk about
spider-man no way home yesterday they
put out all these compilations of a
bunch of tv spots and i didn't know
which one to cover was feeling very much
under the weather a little bit in
recovery right now but i want to thank
everyone who saw our community post
decided to just submit a whole bunch of
compilations our way to make sure that
we are catching the right one so we're
going with the longest one it's only
about three minutes i'm like if it's the
longest one it should have them all
right so let's get into it and before i
do i know some of you are probably
thinking greg that spider-man shirt
looks awfully big on you it does doesn't
it well here's the thing whenever aaron
who is in our spider-man no way home
trailer 2 reaction whenever he comes
over he always leaves something behind
every it's like some religious right
that he has to be obedient to and he
left this shirt so in the words of toby
mcguire you're out aaron
out of a shirt
you're a gobby yeah you gotta go you got
it
[Music]
looks like we got competition
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life
just felt normal that was when you found
out and the newspaper was different
was it spider minions
that spelled the cute boss and started
pulling in visitors from every universe
[Music]
you're thinking hey i'm about to do
something that could break the universe
run it by us next time
number 17.
the multiverse is real
there has to be another one
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
no there's a lot
they're really teasing that moment oh
yeah what is that momentarily the movie
theater is december 17th
what's happening the starting to come
through and i can't stop them
you're thinking i'm about to do
something that could break the universe
by us
we need to send
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
december 17. it's fun catches little
tiny moments each one of these hello
peter
you think your fancy new suits gonna
save you
[Music]
[Music]
who are those guys huh
one of the guys what's going on call me
back
when i shut that spell down we started
getting some visitors from every
universe
multiverse is real
[Music]
wow that was
a decent amount of new footage in there
yeah a lot of new shots oh [ __ ] heroes
you're gonna come through that all right
guys we are gonna comb through this and
see what little snippets we can catch
here i did like this one i do the
reoccurring bit that they keep showing
like looks like we got some competition
hey he's talking with his tentacles
showing they've probably taken control
over him again you know like the theory
has been going around that after the
nanotechnology gets infused into
his uh you know brain thingy what's it
called the neural stem neurological link
neural link yeah yeah it takes over
there he probably comes back to his
regular self here is showing his control
but also the fact that he has the iron
spider legs and then the tentacles
that's that's a cute joke
that's a cute joke this one right here
peter parker and his spider minions
that's not what it was in the first
trailer was it i don't remember it being
that i don't i think i've seen that
headline but i don't remember this
graphic the graphic itself is very
specific i don't remember like ned and
zendaya being on there either his
hypnotic spider senses seduced them i
know that was there for sure that that
was there but this image in particular i
think is very different but there's a
lot of multiverse talk in this one okay
there's someone full-on acknowledging it
right so that day i even gave in tom
hall and some crap about it like you
should talk to me about this okay this
line is new what he says
you're not peter parker i am so confused
right now
i'm so confused right now haha new lines
i underestimated you peter do i know you
you think your fancy new suit's gonna
save you the multiverse is real
the multiverse is real that's there has
to be some joke that calls back to
spider-man far from home right because
doesn't he have that line in that one
too yeah for i think they've got to
they've got to acknowledge that like oh
i thought it was fake when mysterio came
around yeah you got this bit here with
happy talking to spidey about like the
kind of villains they are is one made of
mud that's definitely brand new some of
these shots of the bridge fighter new
they have these close-ups on jamie foxx
that looks so much cleaner and less cgi
than the one in the actual trailer that
came out because he looked like a
cartoon yeah
here i'm like he already looks so much
cleaner oh yeah and more realistic photo
realistic than how he did in the
official trailer they put out maybe they
did this as a response to that criticism
it was this shot here that they that
they used yeah
not gonna take this away from me it's
interesting seeing the splice though in
the trailer before it still could be
electro blast when the trigger before
they had this shot
and then the following shot in trailer
two was doc ock being blasted through so
it could be the same thing but then here
when they slice it together it's from
this fight sequence peter has the black
suit on and then here you got that
close-up shot on lizard
obscuring in the darkness so much man
gotta hide that cgi
as best you can i actually didn't think
the cgi was that bad an amazing
spider-man when it came to blizzard no
not at all it's just help and it makes
him look more menacing
jonah jameson was that a dinosaur yeah
and then that is a funny lie i'm excited
to see how they use him throughout this
movie then right here you got this like
extra close-up on sandman which kind of
reminds me of spider-man 3 a little bit
when he's like trying to reform himself
although this looks way more menacing
than that looks sad yeah hey then yeah
sam is sad gary he looks so sad he's sad
man so this jamie foxx moment right here
just looks so clean he says you're not
going to take this away from me which is
in the second trailer which gives more
of a hint as to why he'd want to stay in
this universe or fight spider-man
because what i'm thinking his motive is
i'm sure a lot of people have drawn the
conclusion of why he'd be saying that in
amazing spider-man 2 he's stuck in that
blue form and that's part of the
electoral character from renditions that
i've read up on or seen him in tv shows
about is how he feels like this tortured
soul because he's stuck in this form he
can never go back to being human so now
that he's had an opportunity perhaps
with the arc reactor in his chest he can
now keep the power set but still look
like a human being and not only that he
gets to look like jamie foxx not max
from amazing spider-man she's a little
great yeah he just looks like a handsome
devil who's buff now it makes sense to
me because his whole body image is
destroyed in amazing spider-man 2 but
here he can at least preserve his good
looks
while still having the power set so of
course you wouldn't want that taken away
from him maybe jamie foxx exists in this
universe yeah
it's like this chucky world how she
becomes jennifer tilly yeah well i love
all the reverse shots we get of dr
strange like mirror warping the whole
city and stuff like that like well yeah
guys i mean there's a lot a lot to
unpack here but i appreciate you guys
being here thank you so much for telling
us about this thank you so much for
telling us about the right compilation
to check out this was a lot of fun once
you guys subscribe click that bell hit
that like button hey we'll look we'll
catch you guys soon